of the fisa
product
note the purple bar
in the middle on the left which is
omicron
clearly a substantial diminution
in the pseudo-virus neutralization titer
which is measured on the vertical axis
on the right hand part of the slide
one month
after the third dose
take a look now again at the purple bar
which has gone up substantially from the
six
which is circled on the left to
154 again this is one of a number of
representative studies
next slide
another study from the rockefeller
university in new york funded by the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases again
showing that omicron
exhibits a rather profound degree
of neutralization escape
looking at the low levels of the blue
triangles on the left part of the panel
however the two dose mrna vaccinated
people who received a booster dose
look had a substantial increase in
neutralizing activity to the tune
of a
38-fold increase next slide
and most recent data from our own
vaccine research center which is the
first in a series of data that will be
coming out over the next few days
and be published in a pre-print server
next week this is a sampling of the data
again
two weeks post-dose
look at the omicron id 50 neutralizing
activity
substantially low
look at the three dots that are even
below the level of detection however if
you look at two weeks post the third
dose
note the substantial degree
of elevation of the neutralizing tidal
well within the range
of neutralizing omicron next slide
now we look at selected clinical studies
next slide
as is shown here this is not looking at
booster it's looking at the
effectiveness
of a two-dose fisa vaccine against the
omicron variant
on the left hand part as has been
reported in multiple other studies
the effectiveness against saw's kobe 2
infection
is about 33
down from 80 percent to the pre-omicron
era
but note on the right-hand part of the
slide that the effectiveness against
hospitalization
which is critical
still maintains
a 70 effectiveness
obviously this is significantly down but
there is the maintaining of a degree of
protection against hospitalization next
slide
now if you look at the uk data
if you look at the delta in the blue
boxes you see
that effectiveness is significantly
lower when you look at the times since
the vaccine was given measured in weeks
however
when you get the booster which is in the
red
circles for omicron
it increases to 75
effectiveness
against symptomatic disease with a
booster dose
so what is all of this telling us very
clearly and very emphatically last slide
the omicron variant undoubtedly
compromises the effects
of a two-dose mrna vaccine-induced
antibodies
and reduces the overall protection
however as i showed on a prior slide
considerable protection still maintains
against severe disease
the early in vitro and clinical studies
that i mentioned indicate that boosters
reconstitute the antibody titers
and enhance the vaccine protection
against omicron and so finally
our booster vaccine regimens work
against omicron at this point there is
no need for a variant specific booster
and so the message remains clear
if you are unvaccinated get vaccinated
and particularly in the arena of omicron
if you are fully vaccinated get your
booster shot
back to you jeff
thanks dr fauci
so as we just discussed as dr falchi
presented each day we are getting
additional data that gives us a clearer
understanding of the omicron variant
and as dr falchi just importantly
explained
our vaccines work
they continue to provide people
protection against this new variant
and booster shots provide the highest
level of protection
from day one president biden has been
laser focused on getting shots and arms
he marshaled a whole of government
effort to make vaccines readily
available and easy to get at more than
80 thousand locations nationwide
and he empowered local leaders the tools
and resources they needed to answer
people's questions and get their
communities vaccinated
vaccines are the best line of defense
against covid
plain and simple they keep people out of
the hospital and save lives
the latest data from cdc shows that an
unvaccinated individual is eight times
more likely to be hospitalized due to
covid and 14 times more likely to die
from covet compared to a fully
vaccinated individual
just yesterday a new study from
researchers at the yale university
school of public health and the
commonwealth fund
quantified the impact of our relentless
effort to get americans vaccinated
looking at the impact on
hospitalizations and death
what you see on this slide is the u.s
vaccination program
has already prevented 10.3 million
hospitalizations
and it has saved 1.1 million american
lives
1.1 million american lives saves
that's the power of vaccines
that's why we have worked so hard to get
shots in arms
and that's why getting more americans
vaccinated and boosted
is central to the president's plan to
fight coven and confront omicron this
winter
since the president announced his winter
plan on december 2nd
we've been hard at work executing
using every tool at our disposal
the president's plan is delivering
significant results
sixty percent of all eligible seniors
including sixty percent of eligible
long-term care residents those most
vulnerable are boosted
and these numbers increase each day
overall we're now getting booster shots
to millions of americans each week
as i said earlier it's really important
to emphasize the importance of everybody
getting their booster but particularly
eligible seniors
and we're at sixty percent and as dr
wilinski said we want that number to go
up each and every day
overall we're now getting booster shots
to millions of americans each week
in fact across the first two weeks of
december we've gotten 14 million booster
shots
that's our highest ever two week total
so our booster program is accelerating
and our overall vaccination program is
also on the increase
in the first two weeks of december we've
gotten 26 million total shots in arms
that's up 40 from the last two weeks of
november
this is significant progress putting us
in a stronger position as we confront
omicron and head into winter
let me close with the message that we
want every american to hear
if you're eligible for a booster shot
it's critical that you go get boosted
today
don't wait
and please get your kids and yourself
fully vaccinated if you haven't already
it's safe and effective
free and easy and it's the best way to
protect yourself your loved ones
and your communities this holiday season
and winter
with that let's take some questions over
to you kevin
thanks jeff
we have time for a few questions today
so let's please keep the questions to
one question sabrina siddiqui at the
wall street journal
hi thank you as always for doing the
briefing so given that the omicron
variant compromises the effects of a
two-dose mrna vaccine
and reduces overall protection i wanted
to ask about those who are not eligible
for boosters namely adolescents age 12
to 15 first started getting the vaccine
in may how confident are we since they
are not eligible for a booster that that
category of adolescents has protection
against omicron and also is there any
cause for concern that children ages 5
to 11 who are being administered the
first round of vaccines um would not
have sufficient protection against this
new variant
dr fauci
well it's very clear that when you look
in general at a population level that
younger individuals have a much more
robust immune response
than adults particularly among elderly
so the comparison there is that you
would expect a rather substantial power
of the immune response
having said that we continually look at
the durability of response and the level
of response in the people that have been
followed in the various studies so this
is something that we will continue to
examine
as to the possibility or necessity of
providing boost for that cohort of young
people
thank you
next question
let's go to catherine bond at vanity
fair
uh thank you for the briefing and thank
you for taking my question
uh two weeks ago the african union uh
put out a statement
calling on donor com uh countries to uh
no longer send uh
donated uh covet vaccine doses that were
ad hoc
provided with little notice and had
short shelf lives
they also called on donor countries to
include
ancillary supplies with those donations
including
specialized syringes for the
pfizer doses
my question is
has the white house in light of this
reconsidered the its policy of not
including
uh specialized syringes with the uh
pfizer donations uh
or has it made any change to that policy
thank you well thanks for the questions
i want to start for the question and i
want to start by saying that the doses
that we are sending
are not short uh lived doses meaning
they have
an extended period of shelf life so that
might be happening
with other countries donations but not
with the us donations and we've sent
320 million
doses now to 110 countries and that's
more than every
other country in the world combined
and as you know that's part of an
overall commitment of a minimum of 1.2
billion doses
uh donated with no strings attached and
we plan on building on that total across
time i think importantly the u.s state
department
and and usaid are leading the
administration's efforts to
work to turn vaccines into vaccinations
and that does mean that we need to make
sure that there are enough syringes and
needles and our team has been helping
with the global effort to ensure that
there are the syringes and needles
the
aid team and the state team are working
to help train health workers to
vaccinate
people on the ground run local media
campaigns and also to launch launch what
we've done here mobile vaccination
clinics just last week usaid
added 400 million dollars that brings a
total of 1.7 billion dollars for global
vaccine readiness administrative power
made that announcement uh last week and
that includes uh within that 400
efforts to bolster the cold chain
storage in in various countries set up
field hospitals
uh train health workers build data
systems and support campaigns to
increase
vaccine competence so we'll continue to
do all we can to support getting
vaccines to countries and then
importantly as you point out
taking vaccines and make sure that they
become needles and arms and actual
vaccinations and that includes efforts
to support with the
needles and syringes needed to do just
that
next question please
let's go to jeremy diamond at cnn
hey thanks very much for doing the
briefing um so tomorrow the advisory
committee on immunization practices is
meeting to discuss the johnson and
johnson vaccine um i'm wondering if dr
wolenski could say why that meeting was
called and whether you believe that the
benefits of getting j j no longer
outweigh the risks and then secondly
given the rapid spread of omicron and
the data on protection against omicron
from a booster shot versus a two-dose
regimen that dr fauci just presented
isn't it time to change the definition
of fully vaccinated to three doses and
if not what more data are you waiting on
to make that decision thank you so dr
wolinski on the asip and then on the
definition of fully vaccinated
yeah thank you for that question jeremy
um so aci team needs intermittently to
review the safety data of all of their
vaccines and i will look forward to
their discussions tomorrow to review of
those data and to any recommendations
that come thereafter
in terms of the definition of fully
vaccinated as you know the definition
right now is two doses of an mrna
vaccine or a single dose of the jnj
vaccine um certainly as dr fauci has
demonstrated and even our cdc data have
also demonstrated
we are continuing to follow that science
and it is literally evolving daily and
as that of science evolves we will
continue to review the data and update
our recommendations as necessary
next question
all right go through a few more josh
wingrove at bloomberg
hi there thank you so much can you give
us a sense of what employers and schools
should be doing
right now we're seeing a lot of
employers put on hold their return to
office strategies we're seeing schools
and colleges
move to virtual or warn about the need
to move to virtual we're seeing
widespread outbreaks in major league
sports leagues for instance do we think
that this is mostly
uh the delta surge that we're seeing
across the midwest and northeast or is
this believed to be that plus
omicron and do you think overall that we
need to be in essence locking down a
little bit again should employers should
schools
be taking the precautions that we're
seeing or are they overreacting thank
you
dr wolinski
yeah maybe i'll start josh and just say
you know our guidance from the cdc has
actually been um very clear as to what
we should be doing and preventing these
um
these cases from happening of course as
we've been saying getting vaccinated
getting boosted especially with emerging
data that the boost will really be
helpful both with regard to delta but
also with regard to omicron but also our
masking guidance has actually not
changed in areas of substantial or high
transmission we should be having public
indoor masking for everyone vaccinated
or unvaccinated that is 90 of the
counties right now adding ventilation
adding distancing and hand washing all
of those continue to hold and continue
to serve us very well in preventing
disease and we would just encourage um
local jurisdictions to employ the
interventions that we know work
yeah i would just add consistent with
what dr wilski just said you know we
have the tools
to fight this virus including omicron
and we're in a very different and
stronger place
than we were a year ago and there is no
need
to lock down we have
effective vaccines dr fauci just talked
about including against omicron we have
booster shots for all adults
we have now a vaccine for kids age 5 and
11.
that means we now have vaccines for 95
percent of americans
we know how to keep our kids in school
and our businesses open
and we're not going to shut down our
economy in any way we're going to keep
our schools and our businesses
open
next question
go to serena marshall at now this news
thank you so much for doing this
hey you're cutting out
we're having trouble hearing you
all right
hey we'll we'll just get back to you
let's go ahead and go to our last
question let's go to brenda goodman at
webmd
can you hear me
can you hear me now yes
um
americans are really tired and there's
kind of a feeling of exhaustion out
there
from people that i'm talking to you know
we're heading into our third year and
omicron is just um right around the
corner and i think people are trying to
read a really confusing set of tea
leaves you know it's more transmissible
the illness that causes may be less
severe particularly if you have some
kind of underlying immunity so given all
this complex due of factors and i know
you've been looking at all of them how
worried should americans be about
omicron which is you know could be
causing a surge we've heard around you
know january or so
dr fauci
yeah well again getting back to the
theme that we have all been underscoring
if you are unvaccinated you are very
vulnerable not only to the existing
delta surge that we are experiencing
but also to omicron and when you hear
about omicron being less severe or not
and you hear about those other things it
doesn't matter if you are unvaccinated
you need to get vaccinated to diminish
your vulnerability and if you are
vaccinated to get boosted it is very
difficult to predict
as you say to read the tea leaves so if
you can't read the tea leaves accurately
then do the things that we've been
recommending all of the recommendations
from the cdc
about prudence and wearing masks in
indoor crowded places that are public
settings but also continue to understand
the importance for yourselves and your
families in your community of getting
vaccinated those are the tools we have
if we didn't have these tools i would be
telling you to really really be worried
but we have tools so get vaccinated get
boosted and the alleviation of the
concern even though we take all of this
very seriously
thank you jeff
good well thank you everybody we look
forward to the next briefing
you